the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let me just tell you first about
you know the list of topics so basically
the list of topics is simple it's
everything okay so I mean I think we've
seen in class so far is on the exam
but let me just remind you the main
topics that we've seen so first of all
we learnt about vectors how to use them
and dot product so at this point you
should probably know that the dot
product of two vectors is obtained by
summing products of components and
geometrically it's the length of a
time's the length of B times the cosine
of the angle between them and in
particular we can use that product to
measure angles by solving for cosine
theta in this equality and most
importantly to detect whether two
vectors are perpendicular to each other
two vectors are perpendicular when the
dot product is zero okay any questions
about that nope
is everyone reasonably happy with that
product by now yeah I see a stunned
silence nobody happy with the product so
far okay
okay so if you want to look at you know
unpacked least one a a good example of a
typical problem with that product would
be problem one and let's see we are
going to go about the practice exam when
I'm done writing this list of topics I
think how about we actually will skip
this problem because I think most of you
know how to do it and if not then you
should run for help on me or from your
let station instructor to figure out you
know how to do it so the second topic
that we saw was cross-product so when
you have two vectors in space you can
just form a cross product by computing
this determinant so implicitly we should
also know about determinants by that I
mean two by two and three by three okay
don't bother reading on larger ones even
if you're interested they won't be on
the test and applications of cross
product so for example finding the area
of a triangle or parallelogram in space
so if you have a triangle in space with
sides a and B then its area is one-half
of the length of a cross B because the
length of a equals B well is length a
length B sine theta which is the same as
the area of a parallelogram formed by
these two vectors and the other
application of cross product is to find
a vector that's perpendicular to two
given vectors so in particular to find
the vector that's normal to a plane
and then find the equation of the plane
okay so another application is finding
the normal vector to a plane
and using that finding the equation of a
plane so basically remember to find the
equation of a plane ax plus B y plus C
equals D what you need is the normal
vector to the plane and the components
of a normal vector are exactly the
coefficients that go into this and we've
seen an argument for why that happens to
be the case so to find a normal vector
to a plane typically what we'll do is
we'll take two vectors that lie in the
plane and we'll take the cross product
and the cross product will automatically
be perpendicular to both of them so we
are going to see an example of that when
we look at problem five and practice one
a I think we'll try to do that one
so another application well let me just
mention it as a topic that goes along
with this one so we've seen also about
equations of lines and how to find where
a line intersects a plane
so just to refresh our memories the
equation of a line
well we'll be looking at parametric
equations to know the parenting equation
of a line we need to know a point on the
line and we need to know a vector that's
parallel to the nail okay and if we know
a point on the line and the vector along
the line then we can express the Burnet
equations for the motion of a point
that's moving on the line moving
actually starting at this point at time
0 and moving with velocity V
so to put things in symbolic form you'll
get a position of that point by starting
with a position at time zero and adding
T times the vector of each is what gives
you XY and Z in terms of T and that's
how we represent lines
okay so we'll look at problem five in a
bit but any general questions about
these topics
no I oh do you have a question do we
have to know Taylor series that's a good
question
no not on the exam okay
okay so Taylor series are something you
should be aware of generally speaking it
will be useful for you in a real life at
least if you do you know probably not
when you know not when you go to the
supermarket but if you solve engineering
problems you will need Taylor series
okay so it would be good not to forget
them entirely but on 18:02 exams they
probably won't be there okay
let me continue with more topics and
then we can see if you can think of
other topics which should or should not
be on the exam
so third topic would be matrices linear
systems inverting matrices so I know
that most of you have calculators that
can invert matrices but still you're
expected at this point to know how to do
it by hand if you have looked at the
practice test both of them have a
problem that asks you to invert the
matrix or at least do part of that and
so it's very likely that tomorrow there
will be a column like that as well
okay in general when a when a kind of
problem is on both practice tests it's a
good indication that it might be there
also on the actual exam unfortunately
not with the same matrix so you can
learn the answer by heart okay so
another thing that we've learned about
well matrices so I should say this is
going to be problem free on the test and
will involve practice tests on the
actual test too I think actually but and
anyway so we'll we'll come back to it
later but so a couple of things that you
should remember so if you have a system
of the form ax equals B then there's two
cases if a determinant
of a is not zero then that means you can
compute the inverse matrix and you can
just solve by taking a inverse times B
and the other case is when the
determinant of a is zero and then
there's either no solution or there's
infinitely many solutions and if so in
particular if you know that there's a
solution for example if B is zero
there's always an obvious solution x
equals zero then you will actually have
infinitely many in general we don't
really know how to tell whether it's no
solution or infinitely many
okay questions about that yes
well we have to know how to hock to
rotate vectors and so on not in general
but you might still want to remember how
to rotate a vector in the plane by 90
degrees because that's been useful you
know when we've done problems about
parametric equations which is what I'm
coming to next but so what we've seen
about rotation matrices that was an
homework but B problem you're not
supposed to remember by heart
everything that was in Part B of your
homework okay it's a good idea to have
some vague knowledge because it's useful
culture I would say useful background
for later in your lives but no I want to
ask you by how to know what is the
formula for rotation matrix okay and
when we come to last but not least the
problem of finding parametric equations
and in particular possibly by
decomposing the position vector into a
sum of simpler vectors so you've seen
quite an evil example of that on the
last problem set with you know this
picture of that maybe by now
you've had some nightmares about okay so
anyway the one on the exam will
certainly be easier than that okay but
as you've seen whatever
I mean you should know basically how to
analyze a motion that's being described
to you and express it in terms of
vectors and then figure out what the
parametric equation will be now again it
won't be as complicated on the exam as
the one on the problem set
but there's a couple of those on the
practice exams and that gives you an
idea of what realistically expected of
you
and now once we have benefit equations
for motion so that means when we know
how to find the position vector as a
function of a parameter maybe of time
then we've seen also about velocity and
acceleration which are the vectors
obtained by taking for first and second
derivatives of a position vector and so
one topic that I will add in there as
well is somehow how to prove things
about motions by differentiating vector
identities so one example of that for
example is when we try to look at
Kepler's law in class last time we
looked at Kepler's second law of
planetary motion and we had used it to a
calculation about the derivative of the
cross product R cross V so now on the
exam you don't need to know the details
of Kepler's law but you need to be able
to manipulate vector quantities a bit in
the way that we did and so on practice
exam 1a you have actually an Audrey of
problems on this topic because you have
problems two four and six all about
parametric motions probably tomorrow
there will not be three distinct
problems about diametric motions but
maybe a couple of them okay so I think
that's basically the list of topics
anybody spots something that I've
forgotten to put on the exam or
questions about something that should or
should not be there okay you go first
yeah
how about parametrizing weird talking
trigonometric functions I'm not sure
what you mean by that well so parametric
curves will be you know you need to know
how to prioritize motions and that
involves a little bit of trigonometric
you know when we've seen these problems
about rotating wheels save a cycloid for
example and so and there's a bit of
cosine and sine and so on I think not
much more than that you won't need
obscure algorithmic identities okay
you're next any proofs on the exam are
just like problems well a problem can
ask you to show things it's not going to
be a complicated proof okay that's
proves they're going to be fairly easy
if you look at practice 1a where last
problem does have a little bit of proof
you know 6b says show that blah blah
blah but as you will see it's you know
it's not a difficult kind of proof okay
so I'm about the same yes
are their equations 3d shapes that we
should know at this point so well we
should know definitely a lot about
equations of planes and lines and you
should probably know that a sphere
centered at the origin is the set of
points where you know distance to the
center is equal to the weight to the
radius of the sphere we don't need more
at this point okay as the semester goes
on we'll start seeing cones and things
like that but at this point planes lines
and you know maybe you need to know
about circles and spheres but nothing
beyond that more questions yes so if
there's a formula that you have proved
in the homework then yes you can assume
it on the test maybe you want to fight
on your test that you know this is a
formula you've seen in homework just so
that we know that you remember it from
homework and not from you know looking
over your neighbors shoulder or whatever
but yes it's okay to use things that you
know generally speaking that being said
you know first of all there's a probably
there will be a linear system to solve
it will say on the exam you are supposed
to solve that using matrices not by
elimination okay so there's things like
that you know if the problem says you
know solve by using vector methods or
things like that then try to use you
know at least a vector somewhere but in
general you're allowed to use things
that you know yes
will we need to go from panting
equations 2xy equations well let's say
only if it's very easy okay if I give
you a contractor of scientific on a sine
T then you should be able to observe
that it's on the line y equals x not to
be on that okay yes do we have to use so
yes I don't know if you will have to use
it but certainly you should know about a
little bit about the unit tangent vector
so just remember the main thing to know
is that the unit tangent vector is
velocity divided by length diver speed I
mean there's not much more to it when
you think about it
yes Kepler's law well you're allowed to
use it if it helps you if you find a way
to squeeze it in you don't have to know
Kepler's law in detail you just have to
know how to reproduce the general steps
so if I tell you R cross V is constant
you might you know be expected to know
what to do with it I would say you don't
so basically not need to know Kepler's
law you need to know the kind of stuff
that we saw when we derived it such as
how to take the derivative of the dot
product or cross product that's
basically the answer
okay I don't see any questions anymore
so you're raising your hand yes how to
calculate the distance between two lines
and distance between two planes well
you've seen probably recently that it's
quite painful to do in general and no I
don't think that will be on the exam by
itself okay you need to know how to
compute the distance between two points
that certainly you need to know and also
maybe you know how to find the component
of a vector in a certain direction and
that's about it
I would say I mean you know the more you
know about things the better orbit you
know things that come up and pop these
are the problem sets are interesting
things but they are usually not needed
on the exams okay if you have more
questions when you're not raising your
hand high enough for me to see it okay
so let's try to go a bit of this
practice exam one a hopefully everybody
has it if you don't have it hopefully
your neighbor has it if you don't have
it on your neighbor doesn't have it then
please raise your hand I have a couple
of
what
okay
okay so Oh see more people need it over
there well okay I mean if your neighbor
has it then just follow on them for now
but I think there's a few people behind
you over okay I'll stop handing them out
now if you really need one it's on the
website or it will be here at the end of
class okay so let's see well so I think
we are going to just skip problems one
and two because they are pretty
straightforward and I hope that you know
how to do them if I mean I don't know
okay let's see how many of you have no
problem with problem one okay Oh how
many of you have trouble with problem
one okay how many of you haven't raised
your hands okay how many of you have
trouble with problem - okay so I think
well if you have questions about those
maybe you should just come see me at the
end because that's probably more
efficient that way so I'm going to start
right away with problem three actually
okay so Pauline face says we have a
matrix given to us 1 3 2 2 0 minus 1 1 1
0 and it tells us determinant of a is 2
and a inverse equals something but we
are missing two values a and B and we
are supposed to find them okay so that
means we need to do the steps of the
algorithm to find the inverse of a so we
are told actually a inverse is 1/2 of 1
minus 1 minus 2 5 to 2 minus 6 and here
there's two unknown values so remember
to invert a matrix first we compute the
minors then we flip some signs to get
the cofactors then we transpose and
finally we divide by the determinant
okay so let's try to be smart about this
do we need to compute all 9 - no we need
to compute two of them right so which -
do we need to compute here and here or
here and here yeah that looks better
because remember we waiting to transpose
things so these two guys will end up
here okay so I claim we should compute
these two minors and we'll see that's
good enough you know if you start doing
others and you find that they don't end
up in the right place and just do more
but you don't need to spend your time
computing all 9 of them you know if
you're worried about not doing it right
then of course you can maybe compute one
or two more to double check your answers
but let's just do those that we think
are needed so in the matrix of minors
so the one that goes in the middle
position is obtained by deleting this
hole and that column and we are left
with the determinant three two one zero
three times zero minus one times two
should be minus two then the one of a
lower left corner we delete the last
hole and the first column we are left
with 3 2 0 minus 1 3 times minus 1 is
negative 3 minus 0 we're still left with
negative 3 ok is that step clear for
everyone good then we need to go to
cofactors that means we need to change
signs ok so the hole is we change signs
in basically these four places so that
means we'll be left with positive 2 and
negative 3 then we take the transpose
that means well these two so the first
column will copy into the first hole so
this guy we still don't know but here
we'll have two and here we'll have minus
three and finally we have to divide by
the determinant of a and here well we
are actually told that determinant of a
is two so we'll divide by two but
there's already a 1/2 here so actually
it's done for us ok so the values that
will put up there are going to be 2 and
negative 3
ok
now let's see how we use that to solve a
linear system so if we have to solve a
linear system ax equals B so then well
the matrix is invertible
the determinant is not zero so we can
certainly write x equals a inverse B so
we have to multiply Oh plus like 1/2 1 2
negative 3 minus 1 minus 2 5 2 2 minus 6
times B is 1 negative 2 1 well so
remember to do a matrix multiplication
you take the holes and here the columns
in here and you do dot products okay so
the first entry will be 1 times 1 plus 2
times minus 2 just minus 3 times 1 1
minus 4 minus 3 would be negative 6
except they still have of course a 1/2
in front then minus 1 plus 4 plus 5
should be 8 2 minus 4 minus 6 should be
negative 8 so that will simplify to
minus 3/4 minus 4 ok any questions about
that
okay so now we come to Patsy which is
the harder part of this problem so it
says let's take this matrix a and let's
replace the two in the upper right
corner by some other number of C so that
means we look at 1 3 C 2 0 minus 1 1 1 0
and let's call that M and first asks you
to find a value of C for which this
matrix is not invertible ok so M is not
invertible exactly when the determinant
of M is 0 so let's compute the
determinant
well we should do one times that smaller
determinant which is 0 minus negative 1
is 1 times 1 minus 3 times that
determinant which is 0 plus 1 is 1 and
then we have plus C times the lower-left
determinant which is 2 times 1 minus 0
is 2 okay so that gives us 1 minus 2
plus 2 C so 1 minus 3 is negative 2 plus
2 C that's 0 when C equals 1 okay so for
C equals 1 this matrix is not invertible
for other values it is invertible okay
so it goes on to say well let's look at
this value of C and let's look at the
system MX equals 0 so I'm going to put
that value 1 in there ok so now if we
look at M x equals 0 well this has
either no solution or infinitely many
solutions but here there's an obvious
solution namely x equals 0 is a solution
ok maybe let me rewrite it maggio
metrically that's X plus 5y plus Z
equals 0 to X minus Z equals 0 and X
plus y equals 0
ok so you see we have an obvious
solution 0 0 0 but we have more
solutions how do we find more solutions
well XYZ is a solution if it's in all
three of these planes that's a way to
think about it so probably we're
actually in this situation
we're in fact we have three planes that
are all passing for the origin and all
parallel to the same line and so that
would be the line of solutions so to
find it actually we can think of this as
follows so the first observation is that
actually in this situation we don't need
all three equations gave the fact that
the system has infinitely many solutions
means but actually one of the equations
is redundant so if you look about you
know if you look at it for long enough
you see for example if you multiply
three times this equation and you
subtract that one then you will get the
first equation right three times X plus
y minus two X minus Z will be X plus
three y plus Z now we don't actually
need to see that to solve the problem
I'm just showing you that's what happens
when you have a matrix with determinant
0 one of the equations somehow is you
know a duplicate of the others we don't
actually need to figure out how exactly
but so what that means is really we want
to solve let's say start with two of the
equations so to find a solution we can
observe that the first equation says
actually that XYZ dot product with 1 3 1
equals 0 and the second equation says X
Y Z dot product with 2 0 negative 1 is 0
and the third equation if we really want
to keep it says we should be also having
this now these equations now written
like this we're just saying we want an
XYZ that's perpendicular to these
vectors so let's forget this one and
let's just look at these two they're
saying
we want a vector that's perpendicular to
these two given vectors how do we find
that we do the cross-product okay so to
find XYZ perpendicular to 1 for a 1 & 2
0 1 to 0 negative 1 we take the
cross-product and that will give us
something well let me just give you the
answer I'm sure you know how to do cross
products by now I don't have the answer
here so I guess I have to do it okay one
way 1 2 0 negative 1 that should be
negative 3 1 2 probably positive 3 and
then negative 6
okay so that's a solution and any
multiple of that is a solution so if you
like you know neatly simplified answers
you could say negative 1 1 negative 2 if
you like larger numbers you can multiply
that by a million that's also a solution
ok
any questions about it yes that's
correct
if you pick you know if you pick these
two guys instead you will get the same
solution well up to a multiple could be
that if you do the cross product of
these two guys you actually get
something that's you know a multiple row
actually I think if you do the cross
product of the first and third one you
will get actually minus one one minus
two the smaller one but it doesn't
matter I mean it's really in the same
direction this is all because a plane
has actually normal vectors of all sizes
yes I don't think so because see okay so
an important thing to learn about cross
product is we compute the miners but
then we put a minus sign on the second
component okay so the coefficient of J
in here the second component you do 1
times minus 1 minus 2 times 1 that's
negative 3 indeed but when you actually
change that to a positive 3 yes
so do we have to well we don't have
parametric equations here oh by solving
by elimination well if it says that you
have to use vector methods when you
should use vector methods okay if says
you should use vectors and matrices then
you're expected to do it that way yes so
it depends what the problem is asking
okay question is is it enough to find
the components of a vector or do we have
to find the equation of a line here it
says find one solution using vector
operations so we have found one solution
if you wanted to find the line then it
would be all the other things that are
proportional to this so it would be
maybe minus 80 80 minus 60 right all the
multiples of that vector we do because
zero zero zero is an obvious solution
here okay yes so maybe I should okay
I'll fight back on the board you had
another question
not quite okay so let me explain first
how we get all the solutions and how why
I did that cross-product I see that's a
topic
okay so first of all why did I take that
cross product again so I took first
product because I looked at my three
equations and I observed that my Freight
equations can be reformulated in terms
of these dot products okay saying that
XYZ is actually perpendicular to these
guys and these guys are the normal
vectors to the planes remember to be in
all three planes it needs to be
perpendicular to the normal vectors so
that's how we got here and now if we
want something that's perpendicular to a
bunch of given vectors well to be
perpendicular to two vectors an easy way
to find one is to take the cross product
and if you take any two of them you will
get something that's the same up to
scaling so now what it means
geometrically is that well we have our
three planes and they are all parallel
they all actually contain the same line
and we know that I do have a case
because they all pass for the origin
okay the pass for the origin because the
constant terms are just zero so what
happens is that the normal vectors to
these planes and in fact all
perpendicular to that line gave the
normal vectors
actually all save this line is vertical
the normal vectors are all going to be
horizontal well it's kind of hard to
roll it and so by taking the cross
product between two of the normal
vectors we found this direction so now
to find actually all the solutions so
what we know so far is that we have this
direction - 3 3 - 6 that is going to be
parallel to the line of intersections
let me go it here for example in this 5
3 - 6 and so now we have one particular
solution 0 0 0 actually we have found
another one - which is minus 3 3 minus 6
but anyway so now the line of solutions
as parametric equation x equals minus VT
y equals 80 Z equals negative 60 or you
know any anything proportional to that
ok so that's how we would find all the
solutions if we wanted them
all right
it's almost time so I think I need to
jump ahead to other problems so let's
see problem 4
I think problem for you can probably
find for yourselves it's a reasonably
straightforward parametric equations
problem you just have to find you know
the coordinates of that point P and for
that it's very simple trig problem 5
find the area of a space triangle
sounds like a cross-product find the
equation of a plane also sounds like a
cross-product okay and find the
intersection of this plane with a line
means we find first regarding equation
of a line and then we plug that into the
equation of a plane to get where they
intersect okay does that sound
reasonable okay who is this parrot about
problem five okay let me repeat problem
five so first part we have to find the
area of a triangle and the way to do
that is to just do one half of the
length of a cross product between no so
if we have three points p0 p1 p2 then
maybe we can form vectors p 0 p 1 and p
0 P 2 and if we take the cross product
and take the length of that and divide
by 2 that will give us the area of the
triangle okay so here turns out that
this guy is 1 1 2 if I look at the
solutions so you will end up with square
root of 6 over 2 the second one is
asking you for the equation of the plane
well containing these five points well
first of all we know that the normal
vector to the plane is going to be given
by this cross product again
okay so
that means that the equation of a plane
will be of the form X plus y plus 2z
equals something okay just the
coefficients here come from the normal
vector and to find what goes on the
right hand side we just plug in any
other points so if we plug in p 0 which
is p 0 is 2 1 0 then 2 plus 1 seems like
it's way and if you want to double-check
your answer you can take P 1 and P 2 and
check that you also get free it's a good
way to check your answer ok and then the
third part so we have a line parallel to
the vector V equals 1 1 1 over point s
which is minus 1 0 0 that means you can
find its parametric equation ok so X
will be starts at minus 1 increases at
right 1 Y starts at 0 increase that rate
1 Z starts at 0 increases at right 1
you plug these into the plane equation
and that will tell you where they
intersect is that clear
ok ok and now in the last 1 minute on
that side I have one minute
let me just say very quickly oh well do
you want to hear about problem 6 anyway
very quickly yeah okay
so problem 6 you know it's one of these
like vector calculations so it says we
have a position vector R and it asks you
how do we find the derivative of r dot r
well remember we have the product rule
for taking the derivative okay
UV prime is U prime V Plus UV Prime also
applies for dot product so that's dr/dt
dot r plus r dot dr/dt and these are
both the same thing
so you get two dot d R DT but the oddity
is V that's the velocity vector okay
hopefully you've seen things like that
now it says show that if R has constant
length then on VI perpendicular so all
you need to write basically is we
assumed our length R is constant that's
what it says R has constant length well
how do we get to say something we
probably want to reduce to that well if
R is constant in length then R that r is
also constant and so that means D by DT
of dot R is 0 but what it means to be
constant and so that means that V is 0
that means R is perpendicular to V ok
that's a proof it's not very it's not a
scary poof and then the last question of
the exam says
let's continue to assume that our has
constant length and let's try to find
our dot a so if there's acceleration
then probably we should bring it in
somewhere maybe by taking a derivative
of something okay so if we know that r
dot V equals zero let's take the
derivative of that that's still zero but
now using the product rule
well dr/dt is v dot v plus r dot DV DT
is going to be zero so that means that
you're asked about r dot a well that's
equal to minus V dot V okay and that's
it